Poor people need it, rich people keep it,
and only few can resist it.
It can make us happy, but not always.
Intrinsically it has zero value, but then
it’s maybe the only thing in this world
we all agree to trust.
To see how money came about, it helps to understand
its history.
First, there was barter, a system in which
people simply exchanged what they wanted with
what they had.
This simple trade of goods led to an immense
increase in specialization, economic growth
and wealth.
To find each other and exchange what they
had for what they needed, people formed markets.
To ensure that their produce can be trusted,
they later invented brands.
But there was a problem.
Barter is based on a "double coincidence of
wants", which means that people who wanted
each other's stuff, also had to find another.
In a world without forms of telecommunications
this wasn’t easy.
And as a result they often had to go an extra
mile to find their luck.
Around 3,500 years ago someone came up with
the idea to weigh products in the form of
rare metals and gold and silver became a medium
of exchange.
This was possible because there was a shared
belief that gold was as beautiful as it was
scarce.
Gold allowed us to replace barter, and make
and sell things, and then save the income
of our earning.
The ability to store value was born.
This meant we were able to take the earnings
of our work into the future, which led to
an immense increase in innovation and specialization.
Trade exploded and as a result, a lot of wealth
was created.
Around 1,000 years ago, some smart businessmen
realized that trust itself was as good as
gold.
In exchange for goods, they simply promised
the seller to give them the gold later and
handed them a letter of credit instead..
Paper notes had the advantage that they were
lighter than gold, and easier to count, store
and protect.
Rulers and politicians then soon realized
that they can issue these notes themselves
and started prohibiting others to do so.
To win the trust of their people, they promised
to pay back every note with an equivalent
amount of gold.
Around 100 years ago rulers began craving
for more money than they had, and so they
stopped backing it with gold, and just began
printing as many notes as they needed — the
so-called fiat money was born.
The newly printed money was often given to
business owners in the form of cheap loans.
This allowed them to invest, hire, and increase
economic activity.
Employees who earned and saved that money
realized that while prices of everyday goods
went up over time, the buying power of their
savings went down.
As a result they often spend their savings
fast— further increasing economic activity.
But soon some began to understand that while
their incomes remained relatively flat, housing
and company stocks kept rising and rising
Inflation of asset prices happened because
while there was more and more money, there
was still just the same limited amount of
land to buy.
Some started to argue that whenever governments
print new money, they effectively reduce the
savings of the poor and increase the prices
of homes, usually owned by the rich.
This is one reason people began searching
for a new form of money.
Cryptocurrencies, like Bitcoin, are the latest
form of money.
They work just like the others because people
can place trust in them.
Unlike fiat money, bitcoins are created by
a decentralized network of mathematical code.
That means that they can be transferred directly
from person to person without the involvement
of middlemen and no-one can increase the fixed
amount of 21 million bitcoins there are - which
is the main reason people trust and save them.
What do you think?
Will history end here and bitcoin become and
remain the last form of money?
And if bitcoins disappear again, which form
of money can we all agree to trust going forward?
Before you make your argument, you may want
to know that so-called honest or good money
usually has five characteristics:
Scarcity
Durability
Portability
Divisibility
If you found this helpful, check out our other
videos and subscribe.
If you want to support our work, join us on
patreon.com/sprouts.
For more information and additional contents,
visit sproutsschools.com